well can you take us into that world
like when do you begin watching them and
what's an average day like for you your
co-partner Theo Dumont and then
whoever's involved and watching them go
through like what's that like well it's
basically uh you know early on it's a it
starts pretty early I mean you know say
our run now really now going forward you
know we'll get together at times we can
and usually weekends and and just resent
you sit down and just and watch the full
day we'll watch as many as we can really
get through just a bunch of films score
them and then with the early thinking in
mind we don't know what we're gonna do
with these films yeah we don't know how
we're gonna program or anything other
than the basic obvious and we have
animation we have documentary if student
you know need a certain basic categories
right but outside of that we don't know
what else might come our way we program
based on the type of quality we get from
from you know other areas like all of a
sudden one year we had French films and
you know the year we have Spanish films
another year you have films you know
directed by women you know it depends on
the amount of volume you get to certain
types of categories so we can program
around that once we get to see what we
have
that's for watching out all the films
but until then you have to just kind of
see what is worthy of looking at again
and what is it that's initially there
early process we're gonna watch just to
be as early on lenient say okay is this
good enough to consider and we can look
at again later or is it something that
we feel after watching the first time is
just this is not going to score high
enough and it's not gonna get in and
it's just kind of that stability process
so let's go through all of that and all
the films and we kind of sit and see
okay now how many times we have now how
much do we have the program and get into
like a sort of a second round then we go
back and ride let's watch these again
and see where they fit or compare the
judges digit scores and see where we
feel they're at or if we feel like again
like I said like say for instance female
category a few mundus we feel like it
was some really strong films that fit a
good program for that
alright cool you know what those films
are score really high let's go ahead and
slap those in that fit well with that
program we'll program that and then you
know maybe then go back to those where
we feel like strong about how they
scored and the films that fit in that
program don't create a program for that
doesn't get we have latitude we have the
basic categories and then we have a lot
of spots to fill they're just stuff that
we can create as far as a program decide
how we want to get creative with how one
these films an audience so that's where
some of that comes into play without a
pic films as well so yeah so that's some
of it and what is your scoring paper
won't look like like what what some of
the criteria do you what someone someone
obvious right like you watch certain
film isn't down to just home run you
know the films amazing you know the film
was just flawless is fantastic and
acting was great and visually stunning
everything was just you know just great
and it just really just you know
everyone across the board just feels
like young fantastic film and we're
gonna program as well
Suns gonna score a I will make note of
that of what it was what was good about
what what a potential war it's gonna be
a for if at all and and they kind of go
from there nothing let's kind of put
your psyche like alright this is you
know we know this is gonna be this is
gonna get in and there's other ones
where you know we feel strong about it
but there's some things we felt we're
lacking whether it's the editing it's a
photography they acting whatever areas
of the film that will note that you know
the strong in this area I'm not strong
here and give it a score based on that
and then will not to go back to it and
we'll know what we're looking for as far
as you know we go back you know what
Ward it could fit or maybe it doesn't
and and why so that's part of that
process and then outside of all that
would be the films like that you know
again like just score lower just
generally don't you know just are not
either just poorly executed not well
made or other areas that are they're
probably problematic for us so we're
just in our opinion just just didn't
work you know and it is didn't work
because again it is a disco ball down to
a judgment call I mean all films I mean
you know we may not like something
someone else made but uh if those don't
score well enough and then they're out
and we'll willing to get them at that
time but we'll score it that way so we
know we're not going to go back to
revisit those films but you want to kind
of it's a sifting through process you
want to early on sift through the films
and see what you have don't have and
from there go back and serve with a
trying to see if you can plug in the
films we watch them compare than other
films of the same genre and things like
that and then and then kind of see where
you're at without naming any names or
you know filmmakers or whatever can you
ever remember a time when you and the
team were really on the fence like there
was just a real polarization
and how long it took to come to an
agreement yeah that happens Assam is
happen sometimes I mean it used to have
a more early on because we had so little
slots to fill we used to be two days and
then we were three three days and two
three days you thought it'd be time I
mean your time is just very very limited
you tuned it was like two-and-a-half it
was a Friday night and Saturday
something it's really like not even
three full days we can only show it was
like 75 movies so you know that would
get really tough because then you're
like all right why are you picking this
films and it does make the process a
little more stressful it was really
really wide picking it how does it fit
the program we didn't back then with a
program which by like theme as much as
more like we just want to try to show
the best films possible first we had to
be that way but be really strict on that
because if he didn't then we're gonna
like alright let's throw all these these
you know these kind of slapstick
comedies together and make this for well
we do that at like eight o'clock at
night that takes away two hours we
didn't know other room to program
anything else and what about that other
great film noses intestine drama that we
pieced now we can't show it and better
than that of the film but if it's a
program like that don't really feel it's
fair but that was then now we have seven
days and you know you can may even add
more they have time to fill so we can go
and do a two hour program of just these
kinds of films into our program of this
kind of film two hours of Docs two hours
of animation two hours of comedy twice
so we can do that and then that can fill
those spots of it kind of helps us to
lead us in certain direction is what
we're gonna pick so it's the the debates
aren't as as kind of intensive they were
because again there's a little more
leeway of time where you could fit stuff
in but but yeah there's definitely
something because sometimes repolarizing
whispah and I like that I like films I
take more chances but some people might
say oh that story I thought that was
really stated and you just hated it and
I might say you know what no I really
loved that I thought that was great
story that was really original spread I
was just think getting right those
stupid it was this thing is the hole so
you have that you do have films like
that sometimes that are really just
stand out a lot whether it's just a
subject matter and that's generally what
it is it's a subject matter if it's
something that's a little maybe to be
handed or just really really dramatic or
just smolder that's the stuff for the
vulgar violence like that kind of thing
some people might feel wrong about like
and some people might and I just I feel
like you know no I don't think this is
this should be screens doesn't fit and
that's where you had that debate
really comes out to the I guess you'd
say probably the stuff that's uh that's
more of older in nature you know a lot
of times and I might write for one I
like that stuff you know I like do films
are taking more chances you know and and
and film I get to do that I'll
appreciate even if maybe it's a risque
or over the top I'll lean towards that I
mean by personally me personally some
some other folks on our team sometimes
not so that you know those that debate
but you know sometimes me at the oh and
say you know what this is what we like
so whatever
you